vocês sabem onde estão os dados de saúde
de vocês seus exames onde são guardados
as radiografias a carteira de vacinação
se a gente precisasse agora acessar seu
histórico de saúde dos últimos seis
meses você conseguiria ter todo o seu
histórico com você pois é a farmácia da
esquina da sua casa que tem seu cpf
ela sabe onde seus filhos estudam o
bairro que você trabalha o que você come
pelo que você pede às doenças que você
tem em até poderia acessar esses exames
que a gente está falando
e sabe quem não tem nas suas mãos
você e eu até muito recentemente o
modelo de negócio da saúde é a doença é
duro mas é essa o modelo atual que a
gente tem de saúde
de um lado a gente tem o plano de saúde
que recebe um fixo mensal e desejo que
as pessoas gastem o mínimo possível para
lucrar e do outro lado a gente tem o
hospital que precisa que a gente interne
doente para lucrar em uma clínica que
comprou um super aparelho de ressonância
e precisa otimizar o seu uso para lucrar
e ainda indústria farmacêutica que vende
remédios e muitas vezes até aumenta o
medo as doenças para lucrar no meio
disso nós muitas vezes sem capacidade de
discernir o que fazer o que consumir e
quando a gente paga por mês muitas vezes
ainda tem uma relação como se eu pago um
fixo eu vou usar tudo que tem direito
como se fosse um open bar da saúde
essa conta não fecha
a gente sabe que nas últimas décadas vêm
subindo muito custo da saúde e para
todos
operadoras e hospitais pessoas ea gente
sabe que depois de um determinado ponto
mais dinheiro
confira mais expectativa de vida nenhuma
qualidade de vida e que o uso do
dinheiro na saúde tem muita ineficiência
no brasil
mais ou menos de 30 bilhões por ano vão
tanto desperdício para fraude e abuso de
perdiz you e rabugento dantes remédios
necessários
é isso que a gente vive hoje dentro da
saúde em sustentável modelo atual cada
um uma falta de alinhamento puxando para
um lado ea gente no meio e seja no
privado seja no público com filas de
emergência com exames complexos e com
doenças previníveis como a simples e
tuberculose aumentando esse modelo não
tem como avançar e pra onde a gente vai
pra onde devemos ir como é que há gente
a linha da mesmo interesse central mais
genuíno a partir de nós a partir da
saúde qualquer idade qualquer cultura o
que se deseja é a partir desse interesse
que a gente tem que a linha todos os
atores do sistema como acredito que
saindo desse modelo é baseado na doença
indo para a saúde essa doença que está
muito relacionada ao diagnóstico e
tratamento que se paga por cada serviço
que você precisa e vai para a saúde
a gente trabalha na prevenção na
reabilitação que a gente pode pagar por
incentivos de bons hábitos por saúde e
essa é uma mudança que tá hoje possível
e acontecendo e eu pra onde eu fui é eu
sou médica
eu comecei a tendência de cores de uma
mulher de cada vez e também que a
atitude de querer chegar mais pessoas ao
mesmo tempo fui fazer o mestrado
doutorado em saúde coletiva e isso tem
medicalização da saúde
comecei a entender um pouco desse
sistema
fiz um pós doutorado em educação e como
meu lugar era de médica sheik através
dos médicos podendo os médicos eu
conseguiria ter um grande impacto entre
professora da uerj
tive oportunidade de criar um novo curso
de medicina na época do rio
coordenei 200 médicos a gente criou um
curso novo baseado na prevenção
baseado na saúde o curso não saiu a
gente transformou em um livro mas há
quatro anos atrás eu voltei de lugar
então me tornei paciente no final da
gestação eu tive pré eclampsia grave e
síndrome help fica internada em uma
maternidade foi atendida pelo meu aluno
e internada eu comecei dentro ali do
sistema extrema vulnerabilidade perceber
que coisas muito simples como aferição
da pressão arterial não eram feitas
adequadamente e nesse momento eu me
sentir como o paciente se como médica eu
não consegui perceber exatamente o
momento que a minha pressão subiu
imagina como pacientes e não conseguiria
como seria
eu descobri que uma tecnologia muito
simples como esse relógio poderia ter
vetado um alerta também a pesca ilegal e
eu entendi que neste momento podia
chegar diretamente nas pessoas e poder
fazer diferença chegando através da
tecnologia
essa é a maria ela está bem eu também
mas junto com maria nasceu uma idéia eu
tomei uma decisão que eu tomei a decisão
de empreender ea gente começou esse
empreendimento era nenhum movimento
mesma empresa e foram se juntando
pessoas que queriam fazer a diferença e
colocar a pessoa no centro com autonomia
bem está que a definição trud elas foram
se juntando na minha casa depois eu saí
da minha casa foi para o apartamento ea
gente começou a trabalhar com soluções
criar soluções tecnologia a primeira
delas uma das primeiras foi desenvolver
um software para fazer o alerta da
pessoa arterial e outras que a gente fez
e tudo fazendo é uma plataforma que faz
um pré diagnóstico médico e pode
auxiliar de pessoas
educar seus sintomas e dá orientações
personalizadas para ela em casa onde ela
de pé a própria telemedicina que hoje a
gente consegue lavar expressão facial de
tristeza e de felicidade enquanto a
gente está atendendo e dessa primeira
vez eu comecei ver que a tecnologia
estava chegando para democratizar saúde
e não mais como a minha visão médica que
toda vez que ela chegava aumentava custo
e hoje a gente tem disponível por
exemplo para os nossos dados que a gente
falou
o aplicativo todos nós podemos fazer
isso hoje eu fiz
peguei todos os meus exames o que eu
achei e coloquei aqui dentro de um
aplicativo que o meu registro individual
de saúde
antes eu ficava no prontuário eletrônico
hoje eu vejo que as pessoas têm que
estar com seus anos
você pode fazer o seu filho desde que
ele nasceu no plano histórico dele se as
corporações ainda entendem que os dados
são pote de ouro pra eles precisam ter
esses deles
algumas dessas corporações você
pioneiras e vão ter que estar ao lado
das pessoas que a competição não é pelos
dados a competição em outra camada nos
dados a gente tem que cooperar e tomar
melhores decisões com ele mas nós já
podemos botar nossos dados e
compartilhar com quem a gente quer um
profissional de saúde com família para
cuidar do idoso e também com paris e
também com outros pacientes para que a
gente possa trocar informações
mas esses dados que a gente compartilhou
identificados com quem a gente quer ele
tem valor e podem ser usados de forma
anônima quando um grande volume de dados
é usado pra por exemplo uma estratégia
de saúde pública
a agência nacional de saúde quer
pesquisar e que tomar decisões com base
em evidências para tomar melhores
decisões que a gente faz com dinheiro
público
você compartilha os seus dados sim ou
por exemplo a indústria farmacêutica que
gastou muito dinheiro pra fazer ensaios
clínicos se desenvolver um remédio mas
ela ganha dinheiro conheço
a indústria farmacêutica fazer pesquisa
com dados do mundo real porque as
pessoas estão sentindo
é ótimo eu posso compartilhar com ela
mas para compartilhar com ela eu também
foi ganhar eu vou compartilhar meu dado
o laboratório que ajudou estrutural dado
dá tudo que eu falei que podia usar
também ganha e toda a cadeia ganha
os dados são nossos a gente também
precisa saber o que a gente quer fazer
com eles
as operadoras também podem começar a dar
incentivos pela saúde
se você muda o seu hábito de 200 pessoas
foram identificadas de forma anônima que
têm um risco cardiovascular elas começam
a fazer atividade física e controlar o
colesterol porque não elas receberem
desconto dinheiro porque essa mudança de
hábito vai economizar por um todo assim
então você vai ter a sua seus dados seus
alertas e também as suas opções
aqui a gente vai escolher nossa de causa
para o uso dos nossos dados
eu quero compartilhar o meu que soma
para pesquisa e reflexão
eu quero compartilhar os resultados das
pesquisas públicas e se uma farmacêutica
quiser que eu entro numa campanha eu
posso entrar e posso ganhar com isso
e quem é o que é dinheiro milhagens
pontos ganhar o benefício que a gente
entenda nesse grupo que tem valor
no japão por exemplo ele fizer um banco
de tempo
cada pessoa que cuida de uma criança do
idoso tenha crédito em hora sem tempo
para se cuidar do futuro essa moeda de
benefício ela é pactuada por nós ea
gente começa então recompensar saúde
atitude e não tô ensa a gente já pode
dar mais um passo para o futuro que é o
bloquinho isso hoje
esse aplicativo que eu falei pra vocês é
de uma empresa ainda ela por mais que
ela tinha todo um comparsa e lei de
proteção de dados e ela fale tudo os
dados ainda estão na mão dela a gente
ter um passo ainda mais para o futuro o
que o povo tinha essa tecnologia pode
fazer é tirar essa empresa do meio de
intermediária e ligar todas as pessoas
cada um ligado ao outro não tá mais
centralizado na empresa os seus dados
os dados vontade de fato na mão das
pessoas que têm o poder sobre os dados
que o poder de compartilhar os dados
essa tecnologia tinha um intermediário
ela reduz o custo e ela traz pra gente
o poder de decidir quais os pactos que
nós queremos ter isso capa gente vamos
pactuar saúde
depois que a gente decide o pacto e os
benefícios que serão distribuídos dentro
dessa rede de pessoas
aí sim a tecnologia pode ajudar a sí
automático auto implementável é muito
bom porque a gente sabe que nem falhas
humanas têm muita desconfiança com toda
essa falta de alinhamento já está
pactuado que aquilo que combinamos vai
acontecer
ele melhora toda essa crise de
desconfiança que atrapalha saúde todos
os setores
a confiança é nossa é da rede
o poder dos dados são nossos a gente
hoje já pode fazer a diferença
concentrando na gente os dados e sabendo
e sendo ciente que os dados têm valor
não se assustem
sim vamos sim vamos recompensar saúde
hábitos
quando a gente fala de recompensar
mudanças de hábitos saudáveis
a gente está falando que cada um pode
dar o seu melhor e quebrou seu risco
para contribuir com todo porque o
recurso finito
e se apenas saber que fazer atividade
física
comer bem meditar fizesse a gente ter um
compromisso com ser saudável
a gente não precisava ataque nesse dia
hoje a gente precisa outras formas de
engajamento de aliar o incentivo na
saúde
então sim a gente precisa dar esse passo
a gente precisa sair do lugar de
paciente e virar ciente
ciente do poder que a gente tem ciente
do poder de contribuir para o coletivo e
não ficar lutando contra o modelo
existente
vamos criar um novo que torna esse
modelo obsoleto
a gente precisa saber que os dados têm
valor
os seus dados têm valor mas você é que
tem o poder sobre eles
muita pegada
[Aplausos]